it is time for the Dark Kingdom to rise  symbiote consume you all who will endure  the suffering of everyone I was saver  our intel was right Ultron Sigma has two  of the infinite six six cosmic stones of  infinite power this is no small task but  Ultron Sigma must be destroyed  a suicide mission into the heart of  enemy territory I'm interested tell me  more  all peeps engage  do you see now how powerless you truly  are if we're gonna stop Ultron Sigma we  need the Infinity stones release me  stark and Rockets say he's dangerous no  I said insanely dangerous we're out of  options and out of time  I'm sorry cap can't let you do it  you have doomed yourself  [Music]  bear witness to the death of your world  quiet i her voices  I should store balance between life and  yeah we shells so do you take like  regular batteries suck it  are you listening yeah yeah yeah yeah  crash no moon find the board powers no  boom  [Music]  you